police received several calls at 6 11
reporting a man firing a gun close to
biddick drive
jake davidson had shot and killed his 51
year old mother maxine davison inside a
house
he later left the residence and shot and
killed three-year-old sophie martin and
her 43 year old father lee martin on the
street outside
police say he then moved further down
the road and opened fire at a 53 year
old man and a 33 year old woman both are
currently in hospital but aren't
seriously injured
from there davidson went to a nearby
park where he shot and killed 59 year
old stephen washington he then went to
henderson place where he shot 66 year
old kate shepard who later died from her
injuries
davidson then turned the gun on himself
our crime correspondent martin brunt
reports
on a balmy summer's evening a motorist
dashboard camera caught a chilling
moment in an unfolding horror
a figure crouches over a shot victim a
woman who later died in hospital
down the road no one else seemed aware
of what was happening
two weeks earlier on his own youtube
channel gunman jake davison was clearly
a troubled young man
i just don't have any willpower to do
anything anymore
you know i know a lot of people say oh
that's weak minded that's pathetic but
dude
it's it's like how many years i've been
working out
how many years i've been wanting and
dealing with all these frustrations
davison's neighbours soon learned how
he'd dealt with his frustrations just
after six my son was up there obviously
with his friends at the dog park
he said he heard some either some a big
bang he said he um
don't know if somebody got shot or
stabbed so he came running back to me
told me we ran up times we got up there
police were on scene
and obviously they were doing cpr on
some person don't know if it's a lady or
a man
i heard a bit of a commotion at the back
and helicopters coming an alicopter came
over and and landed in the field and
then was another helicopter outside over
in and then going around and it was
police cars going up and down the street
and
cyrene's everywhere and all of a sudden
that they
all went up here a bit of drive behind
me and
just literally
covered the place in a 12-minute rampage
crane operator jake davison shot dead
two men two women and a three-year-old
girl he injured another man and woman
the bodybuilder shot himself dead as
armed police arrived
it began when he kicked open a door and
shot dead his mother maxine
davison had a license to own a gun but
why was he allowed to
the chief constable said his force
issued thousands of gun licenses a year
we do take firearms licenses away from
people when they come to notice the
police or family members raise concerns
later to restore them once we're assured
that will form part of the inquiry when
was it granted was it granted correctly
was it ever removed was it ever restored
do you know yet whether he held a
license last night
as i understand it martin right now he
was still a license holder last night
on social media jake davison talked
about guns and watched videos about guns
witnesses said he killed his victims
with a pump action shotgun
police were speaking to witnesses to the
shootings and urged others to contact
them
martin brunt sky news plymouth